[Music]
ok ladies and gentlemen he has the
results for the votes and the court
registration in Bell's Hill constituency
the electorate was seventy one thousand
one hundred and ninety eight the total
votes cast for forty five thousand one
hundred and nineteen and the percentage
pool was 63.4% I projects returning
officer for the United Kingdom
parliamentary generally election in
cooperage crazy and Bell self
constituency hereby give notice that a
total number of votes pulled for each
candidate at the election was as follows
David Benny Scottish Liberal Democrats
922 Philip Philip John Boswell Scottish
National Party SNP seventeen thousand
six hundred and seven few Lawrence
Kathleen Scottish Labour Party nineteen
thousand
[Applause]
Robin Sarah Albert 7th Scottish
conservative in unions 40 7318 the
garlic PM has rejected the 79 the total
votes 45,000 119 I hear that hereby
declare that the candidate elected to
serve in the United Kingdom Parliament
for the court registration in Belleville
constituency as few boys
[Applause]
good morning Great Britain folks today
is one of the most horrible these were
five realize I gotta walk today is
horrible we watching today as in
democracy is best I've seen people
walking we want sex wheelchairs and they
identified the old women
I mean et cetera all women whose
humility boy has continued the change we
are sex we are fed up
you have to bathe in your families over
independence in Scotland
no boy where's Felicia the people of
corporates Kristen Bell's whole my
family my friends my CW and my teeth
Union family this is your moment enjoy
it let's go I went to be the seventy you
Weaver as a part a to offer prosperity
not austerity Revo speak learn many not
the privileged few
you have sewing sons and daughters money
to the Tories we are coming for it I am
coming to my sons and daughters money no
longer will be a gap between the
election appear we will deliver the
campaign no more weeks if you get a
opportunity today I want to see one last
one the special dedication to the police
in their forces for their services in
this country but in a the long stick or
Playstation and bill